From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American History and Culture.
This is Tuesday, the 24th of May, 2011. My name is Joe Manier of the Southern Bowl History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm in Oklahoma City, Oklahoma with filmmaker John Bishop. We are here for the joint project of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian's National Museum of African-American History and Culture and National History Series called No Problem.
We are here for a title called the Civil Rights History Project.
Let's say it. Thank you.
I'm sorry.
We're just easing into a first and what will be two sessions this afternoon, one with Miss Maryland Culture, for surname that birth, of course, is Blubert and Vanderbred Calvin Blubert.
Thank you so much for welcoming us to Oklahoma City. It's a real honor and pleasure to be with you. Thank you for coming.
We're interested, obviously, to hear really about your to begin, about your mother. Of course, we'll want to hear much from you about your own experience directly.
That's you were right in the middle of all of what happened in the late 50s, early 60s here in Oklahoma City.
Could I ask you just to talk a little bit to begin about your mother?
I'd love to. That's a good starting point.
My mother has been an educator most of her life. She had an opportunity to teach at Dengia High School, which is in Spencer, Oklahoma.
Some of us call the country. Young people that have never ever had any opportunities to see anything with their immediate environments.
Mom wrote a play called Brother President, Mr. Marlena Luther King, and the young people Dengie were able to wrote it and they produced the play.
A guy by the name of Herbert Wright with the NACP was here in Oklahoma City and solvah play and invited the group of young people to the NACP National Convention to produce Brother President.
Oh, everyone was so excited, but by her being a history teacher, she decided to give us a lesson in history.
Before Brother President, if you could walk with me through the streets of Oklahoma City during that period of time, we could go downtown in downtown Oklahoma City and shop in an store where you could not try on a hat.
You could not try on shoes. When my grandmother went to buy me shoes, she had to take some three-it and tie a knot in it to determine the size shoe that she would buy for me to wear.
You could not eat in any restaurant. You would have to go to the back of the restaurants and they would pass you a brown bag.
Come on and keep walking with me in Oklahoma City. We could not live across North East Seven Street in Oklahoma City.
We could not use the same telephone booths when we were in the other colored. We could not even drink out of the same water fountain and I could continue on and on.
But I just wanted to feel where we were coming from in this period of time. So the advisors and young people that were involved in Brother President got together and said, OK, mom said, I'm going to do what I'm going to do.
We're going to go to the northern route and we're going to come back to southern route. Everybody was so excited and when that trip started and we started to New York City, something happened for the first time in our lives.
We were able to go and sit down and drink a coke in a restaurant. We were able to go in and say restaurant is everybody else and eat a hamburger.
We were even able to drink out of the same water fountain as other folks. Oh, we've never seen anything like this because 100% of the people on that trip, the young people, had never been out of Oklahoma.
So we thought that that's the way it was supposed to be in Oklahoma and the United States of America. Oh, we went to New York and we had a wonderful time. The experiences and being able to tour all the great historical monuments there.
You were about 11 years old. No, I was younger. I was younger. So what happened was, when I way back, we came back to the southern route and faced the age of discrimination.
The same thing that we thought that we had to go through and found that we didn't. We were slapped in the face whatever you had.
They used to tell us that a little bit of freedom is a dangerous thing. So when we came back to Oklahoma City, we were all ready to go because we had had that taste of freedom.
And we started negotiating with the restaurants here in Oklahoma City and they told us that they didn't want to deal with us.
And it kept going on and on and it seemed like forever to me.
And one Monday night at our house at 1819 North East Park, we were having an NACP Youth Council meeting. And I was eight years old at that time. This I can remember that I was not at 10 years old.
And we were talking about our experiences and our negotiation. And I suggested made a motion that we would go down to Kestrick's store and just sit.
Just sit and sit until they served us. Needless to say, a lot of people were not happy about it. And as a matter of fact, there were actually some of them were really mean to us.
They were spit on us. They were kick us. They were call us names. They were telling they could go home.
But they didn't deter us. And most of the young people, the 13 original citizens were young people. And we didn't know fear, as fear like we know now.
We thought we were on a job and on a mission and something that we had to do. So we continued to go back and we continued to sit in.
And as you know, we went from restaurant to restaurant to restaurant until the walls of segregation started falling down in Oklahoma City.
And so many interesting things happen.
I want to ask you, for example, cats.
Cats. Cats, desegregates its lunch counter in a couple of days.
Yes.
A couple other businesses do the same.
Fairly quick order.
Yes.
How did that feel?
What did that suggest to you about your activism and its prospects?
That the walls came tumbling down.
We were on a mission. And the mission would not be complete. It was like a strategy during the war.
That mission would not be complete until every restaurant in Oklahoma City would allow people of color and would not discriminate because of the fact that the walls were completely covered in water.
And the fact that they were black.
Your mother as a leader of this group, I think that who is the approximate age range of those 13 children that first knighted cats?
A six to about 16?
A six about 16, yeah.
Your mother would become such a focal point and such a leader across the next six years in all of the protest activity, all the direct action.
And I'm interested too when you're thoughts about her as a woman in that role of leadership because of course most of the local hierarchy of every other sort would have been male.
At that particular time, I did not look at it like that.
My mother came from a very interesting family. Her father was a dreamer and my mother was a dreamer.
My mother was a reader and educator. And she believed that we as a race of people could not advance unless we were educationally equipped.
That's a laugh because a lot of kids would get a lot of toys for Christmas. We would get books.
It's something she believed in and when she believed in something strong enough, she would go to the end of the world for her.
And I often wondered, I often wondered where she got her strength from because for me to sit here and tell you it was easy for her.
They tried to fire from the school system. People in the white community hated it.
People in the black community did not want to be associated with it. It was not easy during that time.
How did she hang out to her job?
God. As a matter of fact, days of them you don't know.
They had a teacher in the Dungy School system to promote him to be principal and he could become principal.
Only job he had to do was fire Clara Lueber. That's the only thing he had to do in order to become principal. He did not do it.
And as the history you look back over the time, the roads that she's come. It was hard. It was difficult.
One thing about it that I just love to death. You could knock it down but you could not keep it down.
And coming she would tell the kids and she would prepare us to participate in the city and movement by teaching us the non-violent movement.
The social change, what could happen if we would do this and we would do that. We could not win with violence.
Every morning we had the same lesson. She would tell us if you did not tough enough, go to the hardware store and buy you some tough skin and get tough.
Because life is not fair. You must be prepared and you must continue to fight. That's what she taught us. She taught us by Gandhi and the non-violent movement.
We had to learn the steps. We had to learn how to be free.
So...
I'm just wondering if you can talk a little bit about your mother's...
kind of who she was organically and how that related to the role that she played as an activist.
My mother came from a place called Hoffman Oklahoma in a Fusky County.
She would always say that she was topping her class. She was in the top five of her class but it was only five students in her class.
She did not have the same textbooks in Hoffman as they had in other schools. They had the leftover books.
So she would tell me when they would start reading the story and get to page 9. If my pages were to start again at page 21.
And for years and years I asked myself, where did my mom get that toughness? How could she keep on ticking? No matter what.
I've seen her in the adversity she's went through. But then I started thinking, really thinking.
I thought about her father. I thought about her mother. I thought about her brother.
The dad because he was not allowed to be treated in the hospital only because he was black.
I think that that was the basic foundation in the strong belief in God that gave her that added strength.
Because what she would say would happen to my brother, no child deserves that.
So she continued and she fought with injustice as long as she could. She's still fighting. She's still hanging on.
But I'm going to tell you something. I think that during this whole crisis I've only seen my mother face fear once that I can remember.
I know there must have been many times but the time that impacted me the most.
We were coming home from a freedom rally. And we had over 80 cars. You know, because all the kids were on our car you can look at and see the ground a lot of times.
But we rode anywhere and hold car full of people all the time. And we were coming home from this rally.
And we noticed that a group of white guys, men, were behind us in an old pickup truck.
And I thought that they were just going to pass us or whatever, but they didn't.
And the closer that we would get to home our destination, the closer they would follow us.
So the spokesperson for the NACP Youth Council is a young lady who's now a professor at the University of London, Georgia.
My name is Barbara Post here. And her father was a big man. And when I say big, he was a big man.
And mom said, told us, Tokyo and then I said, these people are following us.
And this is what I want you to do. When I turn this corner on Northeast 14th, I'll be blowing my horn and I want you to run up to the poses and knock on that door as hard as you can.
I don't know what these guys want, but whatever they want, it's not right. Now do you understand me?
Don't say anything, but do exactly what I tell you to do. Open that door. I'm going to drive up there as close to the steps as I can get and run and knock that door down.
And that's what we did. But when we did that, and they let us into the house, my mother drove away.
I think that that's one of the greatest fears that I've ever had because my thought was, well, let's see my mom again.
Is it worth it that my mother would not come back to us? Every time I think about that, I just say thank you God for the experience and thank you for letting my mom come back home to us.
I want to ask about, how about, ask about your mom's relationship with a couple of different folks?
One is your family, your members of which church?
Fish Street Baptist.
Exactly. And can you talk about your mother's relationship with your pastor and the community of the network of black pastors in the city?
She was loved by some. She was feared by some and disliked by some. That's just the way it was.
The reasons were fear.
We met in the churches that we would meet at many of them were threatened.
The other congregation didn't want us there because they were scared that their church would be bombed.
But then there was a lot of people that stood up with us.
So, as you know, by being a historian that you are, that the civil rights movement here was based on the small people.
They have nots, the maids, the garbage workers.
We did not have a lot of the professional black people involved because of the fear of losing their jobs.
And even my grandmother was a maid.
And my grandmother in order to educate my mother and her two other siblings moved into the servant quarters in nickel seals to nurse somebody else's kids in order to educate my mom.
And doing the civil rights movement, my grandmother was still a maid.
With the nickels and dimes and the sweat and tears.
But then those that were committed to the movement were committed.
We used to sing a song and go let nobody turn me around.
And that's what we did.
And some of them had to write notes and they put it under our door.
The strategy because they didn't want to physically be seen becoming involved in it.
But somebody had to stand up.
I'm going to ask you two about this.
There's a ball of justice to it too long.
We're back on after a short pause.
I want to ask you two about your mother and the youth councils and all the sort of the whole community of folks who took action.
The relationship of that community to the local police department.
We touched on this before we began our filming today.
I'm really interested in the role of law enforcement in all of those many, many, many protest moments.
Because Oklahoma City unbalanced was relatively free of heavy violence.
We had some small incidents of violence.
But I think that Oklahoma City consciously made a decision that we did not want to become the focus point of America through the violent aspects of it.
And we had a good relationship with the police department.
Mom was only arrested 26 times.
She was not beaten up.
We were arrested.
But I think that somewhere along the line that Oklahoma City leadership knew that they were doing a great injustice to all of its residents.
And that's why I think that we did not have any violence.
Because the good people decided, okay, that I'm protested, I don't know what happened, but we're not going to be a part of it.
But then you had some other people that were kind of mean.
You got to a chimpanzee on me.
And I'm going to ask you just to say that again and explain a little more to Taylor because someone hearing this later might actually not understand what you're being literally truthful about that.
No, no, I'm being truthful.
We were protesting, thicketing.
Now I want my freedom.
Welcome around in the man through a chimpanzee on me.
You know, a chimpanzee.
I was very small then.
I'm a little heavier now.
But I was very small then.
The chimpanzee was almost as big as I was.
And that was not a good day.
There was not a good day.
I want to ask a couple of things about your mother.
I want to ask you about some of your own.
You were a child really.
I'm a young child really.
A lot of it was.
What do you think ultimately your mother's political savvy came from?
And she seemed to be a very set skillful manager of all of the issues that needed to be managed to move forward in a successful way.
Did she have innate skills in that area?
Did she have, do you think it was part of what she had studied?
Did she have an historian?
Do you think she had key allies who helped her debate those issues and come up with good strategy?
I'm interested in your perspective on that.
I think it was all of the above.
Her hobby was to recongression a record.
Now who raised the Congress in a record every day?
I mean that's what she did.
We have thousands of Congressional records where she's underlined the high points.
She knew everybody from everybody here in Oklahoma.
People that could make a difference and people could not.
She knew, and she was like the voice of the people when they had problems.
The problems became struggles when they were a hope was lost.
They came to her.
Nothing just happens.
I think that she was groomed in history for her day.
Did you trouble about your dad in this relation to all of this?
My mother and dad had the worst at early age, right in the midst of it.
There was a lot for him to handle.
He was electrician.
He had fun, loving, crazy.
You would love to be around him because he's always laughing and joking.
But I think that the real pressure that he couldn't handle.
That's what I really think.
We never discussed it.
He died a few years ago.
But it was just I think too much for him to deal with it.
Tell me about, do you think back through all of those protests,
all of those long repeated, difficult protests for years?
What are some of the things that stand out in your memories,
the most important things to tell someone about all of that?
So they understand the essence of it.
If it can be explained in any short hand way, I'm not sure if it can.
It can be every Saturday of my young life,
it was spent protesting.
We did not have the joys of going to amusement parks
because they were not open to us.
And even after they became open,
most of the young people that participated in the cities
did not have the money to even attend the amusement parks.
The closeness of the young people that participated in the movement,
throughout not discipline, but throughout this nation,
is one that you can't really understand unless you were there.
We celebrated our 50-year anniversary here
and young people came from all over the United States
to be a part, standard room only.
Oh yeah, and they started telling about their experiences
and what they remember.
We made recordings to anything that we can because
I'm so glad that we sat down here in Oklahoma City
because if we had not sat down here in Oklahoma City,
young people throughout this nation would not have stood up.
And when we think about it,
it's like a whirlwind effect.
And we did not realize the importance of what we were doing.
We just wanted to make the social changes here,
but little did we know that we had the whirlwind effect
and change American history.
Let me ask about one last major theme.
The 1970 Mother Andrews, the 1970s.
And let's see, by 1972, you were about how old?
Oh, I don't know.
Every year older than I was.
Older than I was.
What do you think?
Tell us about your...
That's no small undertaking.
And I'm interested to have your recollections about that.
I thought my mom was going crazy.
But it was a lot of fun.
And I enjoyed joining her on the political campaign
because you can't out debate mom,
because you're not going to outread mom.
And she's going to be totally focused whatever she's discussing.
Whether it's the governmental system,
and if you start talking about government,
she's been studying government for the last 50 years,
or the educational system,
because she taught for 40 years.
And she was just well-versed in all the issues.
And she would go to the little bity small town.
I mean, it's towns that are as big as this couch.
No black folks, and would say the same thing
as she traveled throughout the state.
And people of all races,
and creeds, and colors,
were surprised that she was doing that,
but they supported her.
And I think that she had just a little bit longer,
a little bit more time on a year was different in history,
but she would have elected.
She would have made the greatest change
that Oklahoma would have ever seen.
You remember primary school?
Oh yeah, we lost.
But it's okay.
Like she said, that's okay. We tried.
Do you know what she told what percent of the vote was?
You know, I sure don't.
But surprisingly, there's more than people thought
than she would throughout the state of Oklahoma.
But I really, in all honesty, I can't remember right now.
There's been a lot of water under the reels at that time.
Did you ever consider taking another way of public office?
No.
And I can't answer why.
That was her decision.
John, this was just a sudden.
No fear we're rolling.
We're back on after short break.
And to conclude today,
we're going to talk a little bit about the sanitation workers strike
in the city in I think summer 68.
And your mother served a spokesperson.
And can you share some recollections about that episode?
The sanitation workers represented a segment of our community.
They were overworked and underpaid.
I often wondered why she was selected as a spokesperson.
And I asked some of the sanitation workers why she was selected.
And they, I was told that she understood the problem.
She would be honest and she was a woman of integrity.
And if she said something, she would stand back and fight to the end.
And many times during the sanitation strike,
I think they thought the end was coming too.
Because on that black Friday,
the Oklahoma City has never seen anything like it did that day.
But it helped change the city.
It helped change it because I think
that somewhere we started to understand that so goes one of us,
so goes all of us.
And if you fail, I fail.
And if I fail, you fail.
We're all in this part together.
The other thing is that I think the mom represented people
that just couldn't represent themselves.
You asked me if she was your friend, not that I know of.
And she taught me this.
And she would say to me every day,
first of all, she would say,
when she would wake me up in the mornings,
she would say,
do you want to continue your education today?
That's number one.
And even then, she would say,
we were complaining about anything.
She would always have made us learn this.
To believe in the rain when the rain didn't fall,
and to believe in the sun when the sun didn't shine,
and believe in a God that you've never seen.
That's who Clara Luperes.
So, thank you so much for sharing.
I'm pretty up to you with us today.
Welcome to Mexico, Oklahoma City.
We're very pleased to have talked to you about the mother
and yourself and your family.
Please context, thank you.
You're welcome.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History
and Culture.